ten seconds cube fanatics one-minute
warzone rated 101 players 1784 average
rating time handicapped ending in 30
minutes experience level now required
doctor is in town here playing the
doctor
let's go night alright yeah let's go
tonight let's go mouse wanna start
let's go Mouse to challenge that Center
gambits
damn its gamuts gambits
9 f 3 I cannot castle Florida 3 majority
on the Kings side what does this mean
let's go slower here not too slow not
too slow wow that nights gonna kill me
Bishop's dead isn't he dead bishop I
have this square covered there's no
clean check coming out not going
anywhere let me do that first and then
I'm take like this then maybe target
that pond all right Knight I drama that
Bishop and where is that knock out you
guys just want to do Bishop here and get
queenside castle I have to watch over f4
from that night castle get the King over
here get in the center maybe I should
have done something sooner okay pawn
push that night out of there right here
is where I want to be okay right here
I'm on that rook on that night as well
wasn't I on that a bit sooner I'm on the
Queen Oh double check where is the main
that's me back to tournament 2
to a bunch of two's okay
black chess Brazil right are they gonna
pair me up that happened in the one
tournament it was a I think whenever I
was trying to be paired up with somebody
from India wasn't working out
I might get some free points for an
error for this one still nothing yet oh
wait leg is in there in first oh right
still no action here I got to stick
around here it's it's not like they're
not moving and I could already have a
pre move in or something in are actually
I should state it like my tab won't
start blinking when a move has been or
when the game has started
give me some points I don't know that
this is gonna be fired up err err gambit
come on come on they're gaining points
here give me some give me at least two
points I don't like to see myself
tripped drifting back here we go
uh-huh after all that those were
precious seconds ah it wasn't even in
ere was uh wait wait maybe I get the
full points if they don't move within
fifteen seconds I think they're the
points are doubled automatically and I
get awarded the win should I already
have the win oh man I thought that that
was like a new thing that was already in
there
they've been doubled the points have
been doubled this should be resigned
why isn't it time for a resignation why
aren't they already avoiding it it says
that the game stakes had been doubled
there we go there we go there we go
that's what I need right there right
there is where it's at this guy is six
points as well
another gambit another gambit not sure
what this is really accomplishing this
is anything good here I kicked that
night around
let's try this pin the night and then
attack the night stay up on the pin okay
this is a problem isn't it
now let's not do that let's do this um
oh that's bad news that is bad news now
they could take and then play night here
or something I like my dark square
bishop though so I'm gonna hang it under
that pawn push
I think that's working because then I
hit the bishop being clean they should
probably take okay now the queen is hit
twice oh I'm up a queen here
I am definitely up a clean here watch
out for back rank mates don't you dare
fall for that you could drop a queen but
do not do not drop your king don't you
dare
alright not feeling too comfortable here
with my uh my mouse did you quit talking
about your mouse just play chess okay
give a check we've a mate where's the
mate
where's the mate pick off the rook pick
off the rook pick them off pick them off
where is he I'm on him now they missed
it 11 seconds check right here right
here
grab a pond have another pawn another
pawn right here push away don't waste
any time
no stalemates
don't you dare try and stalemate watch
out for stalemate watch out for
stalemate that's not stalemate let's go
here don't known to fry me here we go
back to tournament 12 bunch of twelves
all right this guy has a what oh you've
got hasn't had any points yet Irie Berto
one one one
anam mover you get the points for these
if they don't move whoa that's a new
rule okay here we go we have action we
have action now capture on D sneaky
Queen I'm on the bishop don't move the
rook
let's go Knight g4 is where you belong
oh that's a pun with check my bishop
wants to play watch out I'm still on
that pond mate threat are they gonna
miss it that classic being sneaky right
here sneaky stuff still free night free
King I'm gonna take that one G 222 quick
kill that I needed sneakiness okay let's
try the bird is the word
let's go bird ah Bishop b2 b4 tsunami of
pawns variation pond tsunami I don't
want to take that there's sneaky stuff
over here on h4 happening avoid the
sneaky stuff avoid it okay lights grab
bishops you're off let's go I'm coming
after the King now I'm back it up okay
let's damage the structure here what a
line damage the structure Queen here
rook here let's do this
just I really uh maybe I should push
that rook around play G floor or
something maybe I should have taken a
punt that would have been nice too huh
down upon the roof might be trapped
though trapped rook
oh I'm preparing to trap the rook oh I
dropped upon oh you can't try trappler
rook if you're gonna be dropping upon
like that
shame on you shame on you if we're
thinking you could just trap
like that ah man this night needs to go
so here's the plan
my each pod is gonna miraculously
convert to a G pond or is he no he's not
okay but the night is officially pinned
that's a sad story right there for the
night
sad story let's do this
not sure why let's try that time
situation that much time
give me that bishop oh oh we still
pinned oh they're in a giant knot
giant knot Oh forever II where what's
the clock situation just run pond you're
fast you're fast you know you're fast go
go go go go this guy's quick where's me
that's not me
let's try again over here over here
pivot they're down a time oh I don't
have any confidence in my mouse here I
have any confidence no he has not proven
himself yet actually I don't think he
has ever proven himself
okay night after night no you can't you
know six three seven two you know how it
works on chessboard one eight fumbles
too many fumbles let's go let's go
expansion expand this is where you have
majority get your pawns rolling jump in
here night it's a lot of fun over here
where's this night one to go I have no
idea
oh man I know where that nights going
and I don't like it I don't like it not
at all it's not a pretty sight okay that
pawns coming under some heavy fire and
he is officially a cooked pond right
there and a night a juicy night right
here that is going to not go anywhere
fast I'm on this pond let's grab them
watch out for g7 King f7 might be good
or not Queen here
um yepper let's stop the stuff that's
tricky avoid all tricky moves here
could we just trade please might have to
try this again okay now
okay let's support this let's get in
here let's get in here
can we just trade a bunch please mass
amount of exchanges you gonna grab my
knight or is he gonna be still around
he's around he's tricky and he is around
okay King up there gonna prevent that
maybe I should have grabbed that Bishop
I hadn't I had a chance missed
opportunity
Oh grab the bishop again okay that's
alright it's gonna be okay self pep talk
pep talk here we go here we go
victory lane coming up ah no no no no
pawn pusher pawn push pawn push where's
the meat no stalemate check and then
mate next it's probably quicker one
somewhere there anyhow fifty five forty
two forty one forty thirty two way leg
five out of five games um okay
let's go efore let's go d4 let's grab
here and let's go with the French risky
here Bishop b5 pins pins Castle grab on
c5 and then give a check let's do it now
get that pawn
let's give a check get that light square
Bishop and I should have piled up on
that night let's try this now I get some
pressure here
where are the pressure points watch out
for tricky stuff tricky stuff the queen
is dead discovered tricks discovered
tricks everywhere uh-oh this is
crumbling crumbling tricky knight in the
center of the board the rook has to
leave the scene this is me in a few I
would think maybe in one or two they
resigned back determined seventy one
fifty six fifty one eight games in seven
seven six games in
okay let's go let's roll here Sicilian
okay
let's prep it it's being prepped all
other pawns gonna push let's defend
against that around that night
pawn push okay that's sad what I just
did right there is very sad I was ready
to push here that would be been even
worse okay let's do this oh boy it's a
good thing I stopped that night from
getting there he has to go that is a
night that you just cannot tolerate and
please don't castle whatever you do do
not castle that would have been me okay
let's obscure my knight as soon as the
Queen moves actually let's just do it
now capture towards the center let's
trade Queens kiddin come we have the
Queen's off please
figuring the worst here figure the worst
uh-oh watch out for treaty pawns tricky
pawns attack right here know you like
your rope too much let's do this
minority attack I just drop here hmm I
didn't mean to do that I promise what's
still to go with this let's still go
with it my rook has pressure here
they must be scared they're thinking huh
they're ready to throw a pig there I
hope this works this better work oh wait
a second wait a second hang on I need to
defend against pigs they're moving
really fast
woah that's too fast watch out they were
too excited to get a pig there now who
has a pig now has the pig pigs 72 89 89
72 55 come on you could do it you could
do it you could do it your Bishop out
get your tricky Knights out get your
Queen out get developed light squares
maybe
you've done this sooner let's do it now
check to take herewith check and then
pivot my knight right here forks where
are those Forks where are those Forks
hang on hang on no rush here right no
rush
Knight takes right here something I have
take that bishop oh this has to be made
doesn't it make it to one - whoa that's
a killer mate deadly Bishop's 90 jumping
into the lead by a point ha ha the
assassin oh no the assassin everybody
I've said it before everybody should
fear the assassin okay let's do this
that is right there if you're wondering
that's like the anti fishing pole if you
run with g3o
I got a baby step it here time to baby
step it let's go night can I get that
dark square bishop are they gonna do
that yes they are okay let's go here
take that night would you alright let's
try this my bishop belongs here rook c1
I need to get my Queen off the same file
tricky stuff happens on d5 that's the
that's a short answer I got to watch out
for stuff over here - let's try this
I get the dark square bishop soft please
maybe might be happening soon my queen
is there to stay she's looking pretty
pretty Queen pretty Queen position let's
undermine this pawn so I could get in d5
it's not working out the greatest though
let's try this
my bishops there I should probably take
this pond how many times do I have that
available
oh man was that available a ton of times
or what whoa whoa whoa hang on here hang
on hang on
that's a free night I just want to trade
Queens
I know dropping my knight but I just
want to trade Queens I could save this
right I could sneak away just in the
nick of time oh no oh no oh
Ponte spine I wouldn't get mated that's
why we say no no if you're wondering why
is he say you don't know why they say
you don't know that tricky par what have
killed me so bad oh that would have been
so bad watch out for pigs again they're
everywhere those pigs my poll wants to
try I don't want to try they resigned
that's a good idea that's a good idea
don't oh that's what they meant to do
that's that's uh that's what they meant
to do they meant to hit I'm resigning
oh and err everybody loves an heir yes a
little bit of a boost that's a quick ere
give you the heirs hit me with the heir
is I don't mind them just give me those
points though give me those points if
there's gonna be in here come on you
could do it you could do it eleven
minutes and change stay focused don't
drop your queen like you did earlier Oh
was that terrible
let's go mates where are they
my nights gonna get kicked away he's
gonna run for the hills running for the
hills
oh I should have allowed each 600 oh
this better work is it working
not really haha oh I got the deadly dark
square bishop I should kick that night
away kick that night away uh Oh juicy
stuff happening on b2 juicy stuff
happening it's happening stuff might be
happening over here though Forex and
stuff be scared be very scared white
scared I could feel it I can
smell it they're less than 20 16 15 14
they're scared definitely scared my dark
square Bishop wants to get to 83 can you
do that it's a mate not really the
Bishop's gonna defend well I got it
defend a knight now I can really take Oh
deadly night and maybe a deadly pod on
this uh this square
where's main let's just do this the
clock the game is not gonna end it's
probably made close to it though back to
tournament one forty one forty nine 140
twelve games
eleven eleven thirteen double those
points Scandinavian let's hit the Queen
first my mouse is really bad see how I'm
like overshooting certain squares if I
get into a mouse race if I need to go
fast it's not gonna be pretty here Nazi
six let's go get central it's back up
hang on don't be sneaky there
let's go eh pond save the day take my
night so I could plant on d6 that can't
be right come on that fish up on the
roof take care come on let's do this
mass exchanges tricky stuff happening
uh-oh Oh h-file the knight can't move I
got the bishop I'm on the bishop I'm on
the rook kitchen sink kitchen sink
another tricky move oh I didn't move I
thought I moved just then tricky stuff
everywhere around every corner
tricky stuff happening right here your
pawn push the bishop is in trouble
bishops dead sixteen let's go pawn your
past you're fast pigs Queens everything
where's the main where does that mean
where is it
that's me I've determined 160 I have a
lead 160 149 let's go here Hayden change
will c5 III I gotta take knight c6 okay
Castle there's not gonna be anything
sneaky happening here I got to expand on
this side of the board now maybe just
push shut down that light squared bishop
I get that in there let's do this maybe
let's do this let's try and challenge
that pawn I'm hitting it enough are they
that's a free Bishop isn't it I'm
missing something they were missing
something let's watch over that guy a
little bit just a little bit hit that
rook get him out of there get him out of
there
whoa what's happening here I don't
understand these moves get that guy out
of there
um that's probably not the best move in
the world I just want to get that night
out of there can I get that night out of
there get out of there Knight he needs
to go get out get out of there Knight
would you leave me alone what'd I do to
you um let's just take here that's
actually scary this is scary as well
this is scary come on you could do it
you could do it you could do it I need
to get that pawn time is not on my side
oh that's deadly isn't it are you here
gotta hit that bishop or something
defense stuff I don't like having to go
into this prevent I'm in the pre-event
right now they probably meant to go two
squares right there how did the tricky
stuff RNAi sneak my knight in here I
can't move fast
I can't move fast I got the Queen though
where's the main that's me that's me
that's what I only had one points I
can't move fast I'm struggling here so
bad I can't win on time if I'm lucky I
even got that me I'm crawling with my
hooves oh man my mouse needs more
exercise ah see what just happened there
I don't want to go to b5 I want to go c4
that's torture that is torture for a
chess player when you're moving two
squares you're hovering over and you
really don't have any intention to go in
there it's just your mouse acting up
it's just your mouse being unruly unruly
Mouse variation unruly mouse tactics
avoid him avoid those mouse tactics
right there what are you talking about
all right let's expand in the center
expand in the center let's take with the
knight he wants to jump around here
let's defend here watch out for tricky
stuff take my pawn I push here pac-man
mode alright you know you want to take
that pawn and power of suggestion is
that gonna work
let's go Bishop you want to be on c2 you
know you want to be there that King
probably should get out of the line of
fire
probably you probably should do that
here we go
let's go probably just g4 right g4 that
epon better hold his position oh I just
dropped that pawn didn't I yes I did but
wait that's actually a good move ah I
guess it does work out after all see how
that happens sometimes sometimes it just
works out like that hitting a rook
tricky stuff happening more tricky stuff
happening on h7
tricky stuff grab on g6 that's close to
main actually it's a matin to you block
and I come back actually it's not so
easy
the bishop could block on h6 they resign
no there no I didn't no no no no no oh I
would have been okay that's the friend
request I thought it was the deadly do
you want a resign button false alarm
false alarm ah now and okay there's only
four minutes remaining
what's that Bishop up to oh it's been a
night oh this mouse is ugly this is an
ugly Mouse to have to work with here
okay I'll just take the night
if you insist if you insist let's get
that Queen out of there
let's go LightSquared bishop team
light-square bishop here we go get out
of there should I just take that night I
like ah man Queen has no business being
here does she what is she doing um get
out there Queen I'll could deal with the
other bishop or the other rook you know
what I meant let's back up can I get a
rook here please
forks everybody loves a fork take it
with my Knight takes Knight you know you
want to take it darn it
I don't have anything and look at my
clock uh-huh
come on come on come on come on come on
come on I need to just take that tricky
I should've taken the tricky night oh I
feel like I'm dropping pieces with every
move I pushed this pawn to Victory Lane
victory lane might not be too far off
get me that night what a good move I
don't have any time ah I got a pre move
I need to meet
that goes upon there's another one oh I
don't have any time though I'm gonna
lose this look at this this is terrible
Oh draw oh man I had a shuffle back and
forth
this is awful ah ah man I was probably
lose on time if I didn't even have a
draw there ah man I remember a day I
remember a day where I would be able to
wear I would be able to just pre move
every time without a slip without a slip
my mouse one day used to be flawless I
tell you flawless take a bishop if he's
free would you take that free bishop you
know you want to take that bishop ah
there's no way to come back there's no
way to come back you can take that fish
up I get the Queen I need more practice
my most needs more practice that's what
it is that's what it is I'm on the Queen
the queen is dead click resign errs
where are they
I need like three of them in a row
that's not happening no it's not mate in
two three
where's the main where is that mean the
king can run away over here now we can't
okay come on come on come on come on
back to chairman whoa whoa to 29 to 20
can I get a quick resigner ten seconds
let's go come on nine eight seven six
oh I'm in only a third quick resigner
you know you want to resign
you know you won't resign I was lucky to
even get third third-place confetti man
oh I guess I was in victory lane ah
what can you do victory lane third place
not the best though
look at this big bad wolf jumped up
there to 28th
right good games all to 28 to 27 to 20
to 17 I really needed that I needed to
win that one that was a draw in order to
get it ah and look at fourth fourth was
right there 217 Wow